- It's fine, it's fine, shit.
(upbeat funky music)
- I feel like everyone
secretly love a good selfie.
- Beyonce's stylist recently
release an LED phone case.
- That's supposed to help you
achieve a flawless selfie.
- We're gonna try it out today and see
if we can look like Beyonce.
- It's Ladylike, and today
we're testing out the Ty-Lite.
(funky music)
- I used to think that selfies were dumb,
but now I kind of get it.
- I have grown to love
and respect selfies.
- I feel like selfies get such a bad rap,
like anyone taking a selfie is considered
narcissistic or super into themselves.
- If I read one more salty think piece
in like some old ass
magazine about why selfies
are like ruining the
millennial generation,
I'm going to lose my mind.
- I think it's cool that people feel
confident enough to be like,
"Here I am, here's my look, I feel cute,"
like, "Hello world!"
- If you're comfortable
with posting selfies,
I say go for it.
This it it.
- I like how to says Ty-Lite
with four exclamation marks over it.
Ty-Lite!
- Oh it has three different
colors in pictures.
- Oh whoa.
- The back is hard but the
side is like soft and gel-y.
- This looks like a power tool.
This looks like something
I'd pick up at Home Depot,
not something that I would just like
throw on my phone if I'm
going for a night out.
- Oh fuck!
- Oh!
- This is just a flashlight.
This is just like I lost my keys.
- Okay, that's really cool.
- Like it's definitely a flattering light.
- I don't exactly know how I feel
about using this in a dark environment.
I'm sure everyone would stare me
and see that I'm using this Ty-Lite
and trying to take selfies.
- I think this is gonna
be like the selfie stick.
How it started out as a
joke and everyone thought
it was dumb, but now people realize
how useful it actually is.
- I feel the biggest test
will be how it works at night.
- Let's fucking do it.
(laughs) It's Ladylike.
(jazzy upbeat music)
- I'm gonna see what this
phone case is really made of.
- So it's late at the office,
which it probably actually
a prime selfie taking time for me,
because I get really bored. (laughs)
- I'm outside this
restaurant, it's very dark.
- Oh!
- It definitely looks better.
- This is like really good
for me being in the night.
Like I can see every crevice of my face.
(camera shutters)
- This is the one you're
supposed to use for indoor
but I feel like this
makes me look very orange.
(camera shutters)
- See how like, how shiny I look?
- The final settings which is
a mix of hot and cold lights.
You know very good for people like me so
(camera shutters)
- I think that outside lighting,
like the cool lighting, is the best one.
(quirky music)
- I prefer my camera's own flash.
I feel like it looks too manufactured.
(quirky music)
- If you're in a place
where you don't need
as much light, you can
look a little harsh.
(quirky music)
- So what I've learned using the Ty-Lite,
it makes your teeth look amazing.
If you wear glasses, try
and throw on those contacts
for a night out, so you
can use the Ty-Lite.
The glare is crazy.
(quirky music)
(camera shutters)
- Okay so we figured out how to adjust
the brightness. (laughs)
- Which changes the game a lot
if you just hold the button
down, so now I like it.
- Yeah, it took us like 48
hours to figure that out.
(laughs)
- It was great though,
the Ty-Lite was fun.
- Good for selfies.
- Yeah I'm still pretty into selfies too.
This is just another tool to enhance them.
- You can take selfies alone at your desk
like kind of sly, but if you have this
it's like people will know.
- Yeah.
- People will know.
- I mean it's dope, be
blatant about your self-love.
(group laughs)
- Just be so obvious, yeah, thank you.
- Also Ty regrammed me a freddy so.
(camera shutters)
- Yes.
- We like Ty.
- Hey Ty.
(group laughs)
(soft upbeat music)